i have read a lot of books about jesus
and when i read books about jesus
usually they involve the gospels of
course the parables maybe the apostles
play a role maybe the the doctors and
fathers of the church and the later
saints very rarely do they involve a
bunch of rap scallion crazy englishmen
from just a couple of centuries ago but
that is exactly what we get in the truth
and beauty by my friend andrew clavin a
truly beautiful book drew thank you for
coming on uh it's a pleasure and thank
you for the wonderful blurb you put on
the back i will say
not only is all the writing in the book
eloquent but i think that writing on the
back of the book is very very eloquent
too
the the book is phenomenal i say this is
not flattery
not just because we're friends it's uh
it's just terrific i just love the book
well thank you i'll take you seriously
since i can't do anything for you
this is uh
a really weird book i'm just gonna put
it out there
it's a book about
you it's part memoir
it's part
theological meditation and it's part
literary criticism of the romantic
english poets drew explain yourself
well it it says it tells the story in
the introduction uh you know i was
talking to your friend my son spencer
clavin no relation uh and uh you know i
i just we had this conversation about
how weird the gospels are i mean one of
the things a lot of christianity is
about shutting jesus up it's about
talking about what he did and who he was
and what it means for you and your but
it's not about listening to what he
actually said and when you actually
listen to what he said a lot of it's
very weird you know i mean the one that
always comes back to me is like peter
walking on water and he becomes afraid
and he begins to sink and jesus says oh
ye of little faith and i think
well wait a minute he said how many
steps on water have you taken you know
me none you know so i just i was talking
to spencer about this and how hard it
was for me to understand what he's
actually saying
once you get rid of all the kind of uh a
crude tradition and the kind of
knee-jerk ideas or this is what he meant
this is what he meant
and spencer said to me you know you're
trying to understand a philosophy and tr
instead of trying to get to know a man
and i thought gee that's a that's an
actual brilliant comment and so i went
back to the gospel i taught myself how
to read uh coinage greek the earliest
language we have the gospels in uh and
and i just thought i'm just gonna read
this like almost like a novel or like a
biography where a guy is saying stuff
and i'm not going to listen to saint
paul i'm not going to listen to the pope
i'm not going to listen to the
protestant churches i'm just going to
listen to what this guy says in an
effort to find out
who he is you know what what he's
thinking
and as i'm reading this i thought oh
yeah this is kind of like the romantic
poets i mean you know my favorite post
but i was thinking yeah this is kind of
what they were talking about and so i
started to go back to those to sort of
fill in the gap and what i realized was
you know the romantic period was very
much like our period it was
a kind of
period where belief was slipping
god was going out of the world
radical politics
radical feminism people questioning
gender roles and questioning marriage
all the stuff that's going on today was
going on then and these poets especially
the conservative ones the wordsworth and
coleridge were hated they were canceled
for being conservative they were the
ones who start to say well
how do we get back to a place where the
human soul matters where the human
interior matters and they wrote the most
beautiful poetry since william
shakespeare i mean unbelievably
beautiful poetry
that informs changes the way you think
about what jesus is saying it gets rid
of this oh who am i condemning this week
and uh you're a bad christian i'm a good
christian or this one's doing that
it's all about how you see the world how
you look at the world and what jesus is
trying to tell you is how to see the
world the way he sees it which is the
way god sees it and once you start doing
that
uh it's this insanely joyful experience
and that's kind of what i was just
trying to communicate the insane joy of
seeing the world the way jesus wants you
to see it because you you might think
that a book called the truth and beauty
you might think it is a pretentious book
you might think it is a sort of sappy
sentimental book and what's so striking
about it both in the prose which is
excellent and in the ideas is that it's
the least pretentious book you're ever
going to read and it's the least
sentimental book you're ever going to
read because you're you're
you know you'll you'll have either
beautiful poetry on one page or some
beautiful line of christ and then you'll
say
what does this mean i don't know what
this means i know i know i should
pretend like i know what it means but i
just don't know and then you really try
to get into the nitty and gritty of that
and and you're dealing with the people i
mean so much of the book is stories
about these people living in a time just
like ours but trying to understand it
you know in a new way in a fresh way and
they were you know samuel teller
coleridge was a drug addict uh you know
keats died when he was 25 so he's this
incredibly tragic uh almost
you know
almost literally tragic like he's in a
tragedy uh figure you have charles lamb
whose sister sister murdered their
mother uh and who lived they lived in
tandem their whole life and every kind
of couple of months you'd have to take
her off to the insane asylum i mean
these guys were really a wild bunch and
they were all in this little piece this
little island at the same time the six
greatest poets
really who have ever lived with the
exception maybe of john milton and
shakespeare all living at the same time
and it was just electric it was you know
you had a party and people would get
drunk and they'd be but they'd be the
most brilliant people on earth getting
drunk and so i just try to tell those
stories and show you where the thought
came out of it and the whole point of it
though is really about it's really about
you it's about like the the person who
sits down with the gospels and thinks
you know why am i not getting this why
do i actually not think that i should
love my enemy why do i think you know
when somebody slaps me i don't turn the
other cheek i really beat the crap out
of him you know we all feel like that
and we all feel like
somehow
it's moral to say those things but it's
not moral to do them
and that's the thing that i got stuck on
i thought i don't do that i i say what i
mean and i believe what i believe and i
don't believe what i don't believe and i
don't want to go around saying turn the
other cheek if what i really mean is you
know punch the guy in the gut yeah so so
i wanted to understand
seeing that you know jesus was the son
of god and all i thought probably he
meant what he said and he actually was
trying to convey something and these
poets for me unlocked it and i think
they will for a lot of people i don't
think this is not a book of literary
criticism it's not parsing poems this
way and that it's just trying to get at
real truths that matter in your life so
you you say that the time period in
which the romantics lived was similar in
many ways to our own so how is it
similar well you know we had uh in in my
lifetime before yours but we had this
revolution in this country the 60s when
suddenly people were saying this is the
age of aquarius and everything is going
to be perfect after this and we're going
to have live in a new paradise of
peacefulness there's not going to be any
war and they had the same thing they had
the french revolution which is it's hard
to communicate the bliss this sent
through thinking people
in the 18th century they had this
wonderful revolution they thought now
all these kings are going to be gone all
these priests telling us who we can
can't sleep with they're going to be
gone this marriage stuff which gets you
so frustrated and angry that's going to
be gone all of it is we're going to have
a brand new world that's going to be
paradise and of course
within years it devolved not only into
the terror and people being slaughtered
all over france it all became a world
war with the napoleonic wars they were
fighting all over the world uh and and
guys like wordsworth started to say well
that didn't work so what what are we
missing what's gone wrong
in the same way honest people here
started to say when the soviet union
collapsed well gee we thought that was
going to be the new paradise we thought
everything was going to be equal
everything was going to be peaceful and
now we're living in this world of wars
all over the world
honest people
i.e conservative people started to say
well that didn't work what now uh and
and so just like then when wordsworth
said this french revolution didn't work
we have to go back to some of our
traditions to find out how to go forward
he was excoriated i mean he was just you
talk about cancel culture there are
literally famous poems written about
william wordsworth and what a schmuck he
was for not following the radical line
and these poems are anthologized i mean
throughout history wordsworth is now
attacked in uh famous
anthologies of famous poems so the same
kind of stuff the same intensity of
political thought was going on and one
of the things that i think that you and
i know after following a lot of politics
is
you you don't get the real answers of
life from politics you know at best
politics allows you to search for the
answers of life but it doesn't give you
the answers of life and that is i think
why these poets are so important
that they ultimately weren't political
that that's a really interesting point
because inasmuch as they had political
views
they widely disagreed and there were the
ones i guess who lived longer became
conservatives and the ones who died
young remained fairly
left-wing yeah i mean they were guys you
know so many of them died young and it's
hard to know for instance what keats
would have said but but shelley uh a
beautiful poet wrote beautiful poetry
but he was a genuine radical he
genuinely believed in free love uh he
had this affair
he left his wife who then killed herself
uh
what ran off with mary shelley who's
fills a chapter of the book because of
the genius of her book frankenstein um
and and he was a genuine radical after
he died he died very young and mary was
devoted to him she kind of reinvented
him as this angel of poetry but he was a
guy who had been kicked out of college
for his atheism for attacking the crown
and all this stuff and so you you had
people who had a wide view of life from
very conservative like wordsworth to
very radical like shelley but they were
all trying to solve one problem
what happens when god goes out of the
world do you bring him back do you let
him go how do you go forward and i think
that's the exact problem we're trying to
solve today i think that the hostility
toward god and the mainstream uh
literature and the kind of default
intellectual world is so intense that to
sit and say well wait a minute i
actually think you're wrong
what does that mean is a dangerous act
and i think that that this book is part
of that act and and what does it mean
yeah in a world where where we are told
that it is objectively true that there
is no such thing as objective truth i i
love the title
you love the title this is probably why
it is an unmarketable title this is why
ben and jeremy make fun of the title but
but i really like it uh because it gets
to the heart of every single subject
that you're talking about in the book
but
do you have a defense once and for all
to to really stick it to ben and jeremy
of the truth and beauty well my defense
to ben was it is about jesus and poetry
it's literally about the truth and
beauty and i just said that to annoy him
but it's also true and it comes from one
of the greatest poems in all of history
john keats owed on a grecian urn where
he looks at a work of art and the work
of art speaks to him and the work of art
says to him
beauty is truth and truth is beauty
that's all you know in life and all you
need to know and i think that that is a
bit like many of the sayings of jesus
that's a very mysterious thing is truth
beauty and is beauty truth and if so
what does it mean and i think this is
what these poets were getting at they
were getting at something really
important and profound about your inner
life my inner life the inner life of
every single human being whether he's
smart or dumb whether he's a college
professor or just a guy working in the
street the inner life of human beings
and how the truth lives there
and
where that truth comes from and so yeah
i i stand by my title and uh i i am
going to key ben's car
you know
i think the title actually matters for
politics today too because the idea that
truth is beauty and beauty truth did not
originate with john keats this is an
ancient idea
this refers to the transcendentals the
idea that the good the true and the
beautiful are united that there is they
they have something to do with one
another and so when sometimes people
will ask my politics i say well i'm
really interested in um more good less
bad you know more truth less falsehood
yeah yeah more beauty less ugliness and
and and that really is what i'm after i
want a society that exalts the good the
true and the beautiful and suppresses
the false and the ugly and the evil and
the things that are going to degrade you
and this is kind of a always been
understood as a basic aspect of politics
and yet
in recent decades even the conservatives
forget the liberals for a second even
the conservatives all they ever seem to
talk about is spreadsheets and how we're
going to decrease the marginal tax rate
and that's somehow going to give us a
flourishing society in and of itself i
mean what is the role of the truth the
truth and the beauty in in politics and
and not only that we've made it so that
if you talk about the good people says
well you're good may not be someone
else's good if you talk about the true
they say is there really so you know
they talk like pontius pilate what is
truth uh and if you talk about the
beautiful they say that's just a matter
of taste all those things are untrue uh
there actually is a truth there actually
is an objective uh beauty and there
actually is an objective good but
they're much more complicated than we
want to think they are they're not like
you know you're right and i'm wrong
they're not like your taste is
ridiculous my taste is great and this is
these poets were actually thinking about
this and they actually came up with with
answers that are important and when you
take those answers and you go back to
the gospels you suddenly hear what jesus
is saying and you think
oh i get it at least i do and that's
like i said it's a tremendously joyful
experience
that that is so
we've only got a few more minutes we
could get into
uh
a whole lot here
but
we could go on for probably um
millennia discussing the goodness and
the truth and the beauty as we do yeah
do you think for someone reading the
book that they need to like poetry that
they need to be familiar with john keats
and
shelley and wordsworth that they need
or
can a can a layman walk in and pick up
the book you don't have to come into the
book liking poetry because it's about
the people and it's about the the things
that they did and the things that they
experienced in the world i i hope that
when you come out of it you'll think
like oh i get why people read poetry if
nothing else you know and want to turn
to some of these poets but you don't
have to come in liking poetry because as
i say it's not a book of literary
criticism it's a it's a book about
really me trying to figure out how to
read the gospels uh in a productive
joyful and original way now you you
already wrote a memoir you have you've
written fiction for your entire life i
think and so now we're talking about
four or five centuries of consistent uh
you'd written fiction and then you kind
of broke with that and you said i'm
going to write my memoir the great good
thing another phenomenal book
this is also a kind of a memoir so we've
talked about
the jesus of it all we've talked about
the poets what
where is the you of it all and why write
a second sort of memoir well you know
when you
when you spend your life reading so much
when you love books as much as i do when
you love art and and literature as much
as i do
you have a choice either you become an
asleep who just cares about the beauty
of it who thinks art is for art's sake
or you begin to know you realize that if
you let it
art will transform you for the good you
know and i came to jesus through art i
discovered jesus through literature not
through religion i realized that he was
behind so many of the books that i liked
so that i started to investigate him and
that sort of drew me
to him and i think that you know a lot
of people and i've known a lot of people
a lot of college professors a lot of
literary people
don't let the works affect them they
just appreciate them as beautiful but to
me that's not the way it works when you
go to a movie when you read a book when
you listen to music something is being
done to you and if you don't understand
what it is you're not in control of it
other people are and i think that that
is one of the reasons i wanted to say
you know
i i have been
my my view of art has been
revolutionized by finding god because i
found god very late and it
revolutionized all the way i looked at
art and i think that
everybody's view of art everybody's view
of what happens to them when they go to
the movies or listen to a song all
everybody's view should be
revolutionized in that way so that it
begins to work on you for the good and
you can stop it from working on on you
for evil
and especially in this world where so
much of our art is controlled by people
who really don't know what's good or
true or beautiful i think it's a good
thing to know how to read
it is a good thing to know how to read
and that's such an important observation
because now we take it as common sense
that of course art is merely for art's
sake it's there there was the uh latin
version of that phrase which was
actually just created in the modern
times ars grazia artis it's the slogan
of one of the movie studios and yet it's
not true art is not simply for art's
sake art does things it has something to
do with what is true and what is good
and it it is a transformative thing
we've known this since good old uncle
plato we wise people have written about
this for a very long time and so
the art that we the popular art that we
see around us right now seems to be
extraordinarily degraded
very degraded so how how do we uh
how do we shape ourselves with the
better art
my my answer to this because a lot of
people think oh we have to censor bad
art because so much art it is it's not
just degraded it's degrading you know
and the things that people listen to i
think really hurt them and really damage
them and so the first reaction of
political people is always to censor
people but that's not what i think what
i think is we should teach people how to
approach art what it is that you do when
you open your soul uh to another soul
which is what art is art is a
communication of the inner life of
somebody you can read you can read stuff
that's bad
for the good you can do that
if you know how to do it and i but i
think that you're absolutely right that
this idea that uh art is morality free
and that if it's beautiful it's good
you know if it's pretty it's good it's
just not true and i think that you only
have to look at you know
a lot of music now a lot of you know uh
hip-hop songs those kinds of songs that
are just they're just degrading they're
degrading the people singing them
they're degrading to the people
listening to them but if you listen to
them all right you'll stop if you listen
to them all right you'll stop but but
before you stop you'll get what there is
to get out of them for the good i i love
that idea it reminds me of the princess
bride where the character says i've been
taking this poison in little bits and
bits so that i build up my immunity and
that's how i feel about about really bad
works of art and
bad works of philosophy for that matter
when i when i wrote my only book with
words i
read mostly terrible radical leftist
writing and i was able to do that
because i'd read a lot of good
conservative true writing and so i i it
doesn't have quite the same effect and
transformative effect on the soul if you
know what you're getting into going in
so it's it's not enough merely to censor
it but you've it's sometimes said that
you are the average of the five people
you spend the most time with so who do
you who do you want to spend the most
time with you know dr dre and cardi b
and or do you want to spend it with uh
john keats and andrew clavin and jesus i
don't know that sounds like a better
idea to me i think that actually is the
question i mean i actually do think that
is the question who do you spend your
time with and how do you learn how to
who to spend your time with because if
you don't hear anything but the latest
music if you don't hear anything but the
see anything but the latest movie you
don't know any better you know you don't
know where there are other places to go
and there really are and they really are
great so that's why i say you don't have
to come into this book liking poetry at
all but i hope when you come out you
think like gee i'd like to read
something better than what is actually
being piped into my head at the moment
this is such a good
way in i
you know what it's one of the really
frustrating things when you read good
books is you read a good book and then
you finish the book and you've got a
list of 10 more books that you have to
read because those are the books that
the book talks about and i'll admit this
freely on the air i
i try to present myself as an educated
person i had not read all of the lyrical
ballads this
extraordinarily important uh book of
poetry that this book is largely i
hadn't read the whole thing and so i
said well i'm a dummy and i need my my
desire has been kindled to uh shape my
soul for the better and to pursue the
good and be so i ordered the book
afterward and so i think if you're if
you don't know anything about the poets
if you don't know anything about andrew
clavin if you don't know anything about
jesus for that matter this is a great
way to to expose yourself to it and then
and then to go on and become friends
with all those old dead guys some of
whom are still alive yeah and you know
you fight you do find out all these
things that you might say like a sadder
but wiser man or uh water water
everywhere but not a drop to drink they
they actually come from somewhere people
made them up and uh and they all turn up
in so much of this poetry that's right
all right drew that's it you've got to
go do your show so i've got to stop it
there everyone needs to go out and buy
the book the truth
and beauty how the lives and works of
england's greatest poets point the way
to a deeper understanding of the words
of jesus by the one and only andrew
clavin
thanks drew great talking
[Music]
[Music]